[Musique]
éloge de la lenteur et de la puissance
troisième étape sur le canal est une
image anachronique des chevaux des
ardennais les chevaux de trait ont aussi
ce côté un peu plus nounours et des
chevaux tranquille tai chi et noé
ressemble à ce que l'on pouvait croiser
sur les chemins de halage avant la
machine à vapeur à l'époque il tirait
les péniches aujourd'hui il continue de
travailler énormément c'est de l'énergie
renouvelable la c zéro zéro pollution
zéro déchet enfin voilà donc on fait on
fait le travail dans les vignes
qu'on fait à sancerre on en fait un
petit peu et puis on fait aussi beaucoup
d'entretien des espaces verts des
espaces naturels
on fait aussi de l'animation c'est à
dire des balades en attelage les
mariages voilà tout ce qui peut
permettre en ville on peut faire de
l'arrosage aussi de transport de
personne et avec gaël et son mari ils
sont toujours prêts quand il s'agit de
montrer comment fonctionne et le halage
sur le canal latéral à la loire avant la
révolution industrielle
avant de rejoindre briard escale
historique et gourmande à lécluse de la
folie
nathalie folle de plantes sauvages
comestibles habite l'ancienne maison
éclusière avec bertrand à un marinier
fou de loire d'histoire et de nathalie
les portes de l'éclusé restent closes
depuis la construction du pont canal
les bateaux empruntent désormais le
nouveau canal latéral à la loire
ici on a le vieux canal qui vient depuis
la méditerranée
c'est la route de la méditerranée qui
nous emmène à paris et qui dans un
premier temps passait par la loire et
puis quand on a eu la technologie et les
finances pour faire le pont canal on a
fait une déviation juste derrière pour
aller franchir la loire à bria au bout
de l'ancien canal la gare d'eau
désaffecté de monte l'eau et son écluse
permettait au canal ou de traverser la
loire pour continuer leur route sur
l'autre rive
c'était l'un des points de rencontre
entre ce que l'on appelait les gueules
salle et les nobles et fier mariniers de
loire
il faut arriver quand même a à peu près
à jouer aux cartes jusqu'au moment où
forcément il devenait pourfendre
toujours d'accord ap il fallait bien
qu'ils se frottent à un peu les oreilles
bon parler bien passer le temps au ca
au plus fort de l'activité près de huit
mille bateaux passés sur cette écluse
chaque année aujourd'hui la maison
éclusière est un hôtel restaurant avec
vue sur 150 ans d'histoire
les touristes ont pris la place des
mariniers on est sur le passage de la
loire à vélo donc vu le nombre de vélos
qui s'est vendu je pense qu'on va voir
beaucoup de monde à vélo cette année
donc
voilà c'est le temps idéal beau temps
est là
retour à lécluse de la folie ou nathalie
cuisine sa cueillette sous l'oeil de son
smartphone une quiche aux orties à la
berce en mode python chaque semaine je
publie un article avec une recette
et puis des explications sur une plantes
sauvages comestibles donc là c'est en
train de filmer ce que je sais que je
vais préparer pour ce week-end un peu de
fromage de chèvre coupé en petits
morceaux
en fait il ya plein plein plein de plans
qui se mange et yahia kbc et cueillir et
voilà c'est bon à la folie un grand jour
se prépare après huit mois passés sur le
canal bertrand et la sterne son bateau
promenade vont traverser le pont canal
de briare pour rejoindre la loire à
demain